c'est le premier coup d'oeil le style
près jo kg l' elysée purée importance du
duo virtuosité du mouvement et énergie
la fresque est la dernière création du
chorégraphe
j'aime toujours une part de virtuosité
dans dans la danse parce que j'aime
essayer de repousser les limites du
corps et en même temps disons que dans
ce spectacle qui était à l'origine une
commande en direction du jeune public
j'ai voulu aussi épuré un peu le
mouvement est donc c'est ce qui donne ce
spectacle ea c'est presque comme une
sorte de calligraphie chinoise en fait
avec les corps les dix danseurs explore
l'état second de l'âme et du coeur dans
un monde fantastique
le chorégraphe s'inspire d'un conte
traditionnel chinois la peinture sur le
mur de voyageurs sont recueillis par un
moine et qui les emmène dans son
monastère et qui ne leur fait découvrir
une fresque magnifique dans laquelle il
remarque une jolie jeune fille dont il
tombe éperdument amoureux et d'un seul
coup il se sent transporté à l'intérieur
de cette fresque t il vit une histoire
extraordinaire avec la jeune fille
j'aime bien les contes de fées parce que
c'est souvent quelque chose qui
contribua à structurer l'imaginaire des
enfants et à leur donner une idée de ce
que peut être l'existence la vie un peu
de ce qui peut les attendre aussi bien
les dangers que les belles choses et
c'est une façon de aussi pour moi en
faisant des spectacles et avec la danse
lui ramener un peu les gens vers
l'enfance en fait la fresque c'est aussi
les retrouvailles et nicolas godin co
créateur du groupe versaillais air à
prévenir life experience en 2003 de leur
collaboration ressort une musique
électronique rythmé et poétique
une oeuvre presque envoûtante
oui